- taken by Dallas not chitchat ACP on
him to start the game on him to start
the game
[Applause]
LeBron is active to day defenders steal
right on his backside and he got back on
flat Oh read well by the boy LeBron -
kcp
just fun to walk any snip this is a
three hit a three just a moment ago the
prophecy very calm the fun of the random
got chicks weren't number 7070 as
control of it will stop the pop for free
and knock it down with the Dodgers
Dodgers with now eight dionneb that's a
two-handed patch to the Lakers read it
well to Danny Green was there all the
way comes up short
he starts Wharton before above the floor
third leading scorer in the league Luca
Cabot foul we'll get an and-one get
about all the work that you've had to do
your entire life to get to this point to
be an MVP you look out there LeBron
James house
respectful for you to stinking one at
some lame-ass cottage and he has stunned
for a minute couldn't even read react to
get the ball spinning in story he's
gonna try to stall already can make this
defensive transition now it's the blind
the driver
and it goes the other way when the
shorts with with 2.6 to beat the clock a
3 by porzingis our Lakers get the
basketball oh my god [ __ ] I talked about
her last game just a ball fake sometimes
gets the defense out of positron and by
the way LeBron average think of us free
throw attack
look at da Jets that was an ATO from
about the three-point line wasn't it
this last month has been interesting
couple acres if it down by at least ten
points nine times
dönitz hits a big-time threes on the
left wing of this back into a virgin
defense tactics do they see all over
Patchett's inside score right good
assist by dodges 89 77 but still got a
nice turnaround with the Lakers hold it
a step back for jock itch it's pretty
stop huge deficit to overcome no matter
what happens here in the final 18
fourth quarter don suits all the way but
he potted up on AP well that is the
scoreboard at 101 81 it's staring
everybody in the face the two hands that
quick first step that right around the
defender and a timeout Dallas and toward
the line is LeBron serenader
20 with urgency all the way to spin
789 so chances to draw closer but they
can't get it
gotcha big time from outside big time
have done that in mga history being a
month average a triple-double a 30 point
triple-double if they go Oscar lava to
go ahead and open the door for LBJ